[Music]
on this wednesday night pleased to
prioritize kids over politics
the assembly of first nations urged to
shift focus away from infighting we have
the highest suicide rates in the world
and the non-confidence vote on the
national chief
[Music]
disqualified and defending his name we
felt we were going to win this
leadership patrick brown's elimination
from the conservative leadership race
excruciating weights in crowded ers why
it's only expected to get worse
and heart-stopping moments high above oh
my god how the [ __ ] did this happen the
dangling construction worker with
nowhere to go but down
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight colleen christie good
evening thanks for joining us it is the
second day of meetings for the assembly
of first nations with hundreds of chiefs
and representatives from across the
country gathered in vancouver and today
the focus is starting to shift away from
the group's internal politics to the
critical issue of child welfare and the
afn's recent settlement with the federal
government nitu garcia has tonight's top
story
emergency draft resolution number three
special business suspension to the
national chief has been defeated
with 26 in support and 252 opposed to
continuing the temporary suspension of
the assembly of first nations national
chief she says the numbers speak for
themselves the resolution
spoke to it said yeah we want to hear
the truth we want to know what's going
on
and we're not going to allow anybody to
silence you anymore we really have to
work on the healing and repairing those
relationships within the afn executive
and we're going to look to our elders
and our knowledge keepers to help us
walk through that but for some of the
youngest representatives in the room
like afn youth council's rosalie la
bilwa all this is drama created by poor
leadership allowing politics to get in
the way of what really matters
indigenous children who've been
separated from their families every time
you decide to squabble amongst
yourselves you forget the children and
the young people that you once swore to
protect
and if you want to gauge the outcomes of
your leadership then you should look to
our children
and we have the highest suicide rates in
the world especially within our northern
communities
also addressing the assembly cindy
woodhouse a lead negotiator in the
recent 20 billion dollar settlement to
compensate first nations children and
families discriminated against under
federal programs and policies efforts
made to avoid the mistakes of previous
compensation processes
reflected in the final settlement
agreement
like for exa for example we pushed for
we pushed for a trauma informed claims
process that reduces the need for
invasive and triggering questions
members later hearing from advocates who
were removed from their homes as kids
ashley bach says she was apprehended
from her mother and placed with a white
family the day she was born in vancouver
these shortcomings have really really
eaten away at me for the past year and a
half since they were realized and i want
to be clear that the pursuit of justice
compensation and other remedies isn't
over yet
nitu what's the latest on calls for a
forensic audit into the afn
well colleen there had been a lot of
back and forth around the two remaining
emergency resolutions one to oust the
national chief through a non-confidence
vote which has just officially been
removed and the other to begin a
forensic audit and an internal
investigation of the afn has just gone
into the debate period and has yet to go
into a vote colleen
nito garcia in vancouver thanks so much
he was seen as one of the front-runners
but patrick brown has now been
disqualified from the conservative
party's leadership race the party says
he was kicked out due to an alleged
breach of financing rules in the canada
elections act as abigail beeman explains
brown is fighting back
it's impossible to respond to a phantom
allegation patrick brown says he never
got enough details about allegations
against him he's placing the blame
squarely on his biggest leadership rival
we're calling this out for what it is
this is
pier pauliev's campaign not wanting
a fair election
they want a coronation
the polyeff campaign says they have
nothing to do with it while the party
says brown was given numerous and
generous opportunities to defend himself
but won't go into specifics there have
been a series of of complaints and
allegations that have that have come
forward some of them more serious than
others some of them dealt with
transgressions or alleged transgressions
of the rules of the race a source close
to the leadership committee tells global
news some allegations involved numbered
companies in brampton paying brown
campaign staff violating the elections
act we asked him about that you have
more details than we do by virtue of you
are you posing that question they didn't
even tell us where the business was
located
and so it's impossible to respond when
you don't have any details brown says he
has 1800 volunteers disqualifying a
near top of ballot candidate
you know that doesn't come lightly
but i think it would be incumbent on on
everyone in this situation to to maybe
detail what what they knew a little bit
more the leadership race is in its home
stretch and while a candidate dropping
out tends to benefit the front runner
pierre pogliev especially if a number of
brown voters choose not to vote at all
it could also help other candidates
trying to pick up some of those votes
obviously creates opportunity for
someone like charade it creates a
different kind of opportunity for
someone like pauliev and it creates a
mess for patrick brown you know to the
extent that this sticks to him in any
way for now brown says he's weighing
legal options and looking at an appeal
he says it's too early to talk about
next steps including another possible
mayoral run in brampton meanwhile the
party says first ballots are already in
the mail and it's too late to take
brown's name off they're looking at how
to deal with that abigail beeman global
news ottawa
overseas british prime minister boris
johnson remains defiant despite growing
calls for his resignation as more of his
ministers and staff quit
frankly mr speaker the job of a prime
minister in difficult circumstances when
he's been handed a colossal mandate is
to keep going and that's what i'm going
to do
more than 40 ministers and aides have
resigned in the past day as johnson
faces backlash over his handling of
sexual misconduct claims against a
former member of his government europe
bureau chief crystal gamansing has more
on the tumultuous day at 10 downing
street
it's playing out like a viral meme of
how it started it is wonderful to see
this new team assembled here versus how
it's going i've apologized and i
continue to apologize i once again offer
a full
apology sorry for
for the mistake
i do fear that the reset button can only
work so many times
the former health secretary and once
fierce defender of the british prime
minister likened to being on boris
johnson's team to walking a tightrope
between loyalty
and integrity at some point
we have to conclude
that enough is enough
i believe that point is now savage avid
is one of dozens involved in a tory
revolt just weeks after many of the same
mps rallied around johnson ensuring he
survived a vote of non-confidence
it appears the prime minister's
flip-flop on what he knew about sexual
misconduct claims involving the man he
named deputy chief whip was one scandal
too many for his team mr speaker isn't
this the first recorded case of the
sinking ships fleeing the rats
amid this storm johnson is working to
keep his cool
prime minister
how's how's your week going
terrific
like like many others this day really
isn't like any other johnson has made
history for the most ministers resigning
in a single day he's also the only
british prime minister to be fined while
sitting in office for breaking his own
covet lockdown rules but colleen we do
have to remember
he's called teflon boars for a reason
indeed crystal commencing in london
thanks crystal
in the u.s authorities say the man
charged with killing seven people at a
fourth of july parade in illinois has
confessed to the shooting and was
planning to carry out a second attack
jackson proskow has the latest on the
investigation plus the tragic stories of
the victims and some of the survivors
monday's attack shattered lives and
broke families kevin and irina mccarthy
were both killed as they watched the
independence day parade their
two-year-old son aiden was found by
strangers wandering alone covered in
blood he was saying mommy daddy so i
went back up to look for his mom and dad
and then i saw
the scene kind of carnage aiden is now
an orphan a gofundme for his relatives
has raised more than 2 million dollars
and counting the difficult question of
why this happened remains unanswered and
perhaps unknowable the suspected gunman
21-year-old robert cremo iii made his
first court appearance wednesday after
admitting to police that he opened fire
on the crowd he went into details about
what he had done
he admitted to what he had done a motive
still isn't known police say in addition
to disturbing online posts the suspect
had an affinity for the numbers seven
and four matching the date of the
massacre they also believe he came close
to staging a second attack after leaving
the scene of the first while he was
driving and he located the celebration
occurring in the madison area he
contemplated another attack with the
firearm he had in his car despite
warnings about his mental health and
previous calls to police cremo was still
able to legally arm himself with assault
rifles his father sponsored his
application for the necessary firearms
permit the state of illinois and the
united states should ban these types of
assault weapons instead the u.s seems
doomed to suffer more of these types of
avoidable tragedies police in richmond
virginia revealed that they disrupted a
plot to attack that city's fourth of
july celebrations they've arrested two
men who had high-powered rifles and
hundreds of rounds of ammunition
jackson prosko global news washington
healthcare staff sound the alarm coming
up fears emergency wards could get
pushed further to the brink
more than 13 million doses of the
astrazeneca vaccine are going to be
thrown out canada signed a contract with
astrazeneca in 2020 to get 20 million
doses of its vaccine and 2.3 million
canadians received at least one dose but
in the spring of 2021 concerns about
rare but potentially fatal blood clots
and the increased availability of other
vaccines limited the use of a-z
last summer the federal government
promised to donate the remaining supply
to other countries but only sent about
four million doses overseas
right across the country hospital
emergency rooms are struggling to keep
up with demand that includes urgent care
needed for the youngest patients covered
19 cases and viral illnesses typically
seen in the fall and winter are climbing
and as jamie morocco explains
pediatricians are worried about the
impact on an already strained health
care system
that chronic cough pushed caitlin
lavender to take her two-year-old
daughter everly to the emergency room in
pembroke ontario
there she says they waited 10 hours to
see a doctor our family doctors actually
we can't go in and see him at all and
getting a hold of him is quite hard
sometimes he just tells us to go to the
hospital i'm like but i'd rather just
come to him because of covid many
general practitioners aren't seeing
patients in person in turn families are
relying on urgent care at sick kids in
toronto the emergency room is
overcrowded up 20 percent since
pre-pandemic levels what we're
struggling with is the amount of
patients
seeking care for primary care not
emergency care who are coming to our
emergency department at the children's
hospital of eastern ottawa it's
contributed to record admissions in may
and june then added staff shortages
vacations and sick calls
kids are waiting longer than than
anybody than adults than anywhere in the
health system at this winnipeg hospital
one mother says her 15-year-old daughter
waited 20 hours for treatment
and is now in the icu i'm livid i'm
absolutely livid the health care system
has completely failed my child and
there's concern kovid's newest mutations
will make the situation worse new data
analysis shows omicron infected 17
million canadians in just five months
that's around 100 000 infections a day
ba 4 and 5 are said to be even more
transmissible meanwhile canada's
youngest are still waiting on an
approved covent vaccine something health
canada hopes to push forward by the end
of the month emergency rooms across the
country is really kind of the coming
together of a perfect storm from outside
illnesses to
how the individual health care worker
themselves is
burnt out as a result ers across canada
closed their doors or decreased hours
over the long weekend with fall cold and
flu season approaching doctors say
weights will only increase
and access to care will decline
jamie morocco global news toronto
the world health organization is
reporting the global number of covid19
infections is up for a fourth straight
week including in parts of china where
it's fighting outbreaks after finally
easing restrictions covert 19 testing is
mandatory for residents in parts of
shanghai and beijing after new cases
popped up in the two cities other
regions are facing at least a week of
strict closures restaurants are limited
to takeout only and attractions like
karaoke lounges and casinos have been
closed
the streets of mecca are once again
filling up with muslim pilgrims as saudi
arabia welcomes international visitors
for the hajj pilgrimage for the first
time since the beginning of the pandemic
more than one million people are
expected to take part in the five-day
ritual a big jump from the 60 000 who
attended last year but still
significantly fewer than the 2.5 million
in 2019.
in the 133 days since russia's invasion
of ukraine the united nations refugee
agency says 9 million people have fled
the country
those numbers are expected to grow the
governor of donetsk is calling on the
region's 350 thousand remaining
residents to leave as russian forces
continue to take aim at markets homes
and other civilian targets southwest of
there video from local emergency
services shows the situation in miko
live where the city's mayor says a
residential area was hit by rockets late
tuesday
worldwide the number of people dealing
with hunger on a daily basis is climbing
rapidly a new united nations report
found in 2021 more than 820 million
people were living with food insecurity
and frequent nutrition deficits that's
an increase of about 150 million people
since the outbreak of the pandemic the
report warns the situation will only get
worse due to the ongoing supply chain
challenges and the war in ukraine a
country which previously produced a huge
amount of grain for export
blowing the whistle ahead why some
former group home workers claimed
children's lives were put at risk
in may with no public announcement child
welfare company connor holmes
surrendered its license to operate
foster care homes while the ontario
government says connor homes is unfit to
run foster care homes the company is
still allowed to operate group homes our
team at global news in partnership with
aptn has also been looking into connor
homes our carolyn jarvis joins us now
from toronto carolyn
colleen while we were investigating
connor holmes management sent this email
to staff saying no one can make public
statements to the media not now or ever
but the former workers you're about to
hear from are blowing the whistle saying
some kids are being put in danger
it's awful it's just money focused if
they cared about the kids you never saw
it they should be shut down we have
agreed to hide the identities of these
former connor holmes workers because of
the risk of reprisal still they insisted
their message be heard i just felt like
i was creating monsters out of the kids
for 46 years connor homes operated
foster care and group homes and it still
runs three group homes in eastern
ontario
a for-profit business funded in part by
taxpayer dollars i feel like they just
cared about the money and not the kids
former workers say making money meant
cutting costs one of the youth was going
to school and connor homes put their
schoolwork in a grocery bag as if the
kid needs any other type of sign that
they're a group home kid workers say
christmas gifts were mostly clothing
instead of toys because budgets were too
tight to afford both the youth were
lower than anybody and management had
this power trip the imbalance of power
was seen in many ways say workers
including the unjustified use of
physical restraints
a practice the government only allows if
a child is at imminent risk of hurting
themselves or others were they telling
you to restrain when there was no
imminent risk that's correct we were
told to restrain them if they break a
plate according to the ministry of
children community and social services
breaking the rules isn't a new thing for
connor holmes
in 2017 a fire at one of its homes
killed a youth and a worker
two separate investigations found issues
at the home including a window made of
plexiglas blocking an escape route
though conor holmes was found not to
have violated the fire code
four years later at a different home
ministry inspectors reported plexiglas
was being used again asking is the fire
marshal aware they would just put that
there as a quick fix to make sure they
didn't have to pay for a new window
inspectors noted the plexiglas issue was
addressed
passing an inspection was critical to
having connor's license renewed and in
secretly recorded audio from september
2020 a manager is heard preparing staff
for a ministry visit what is a level two
serious occurrence
everybody has questions
workers who say they were put on the job
with as little as three hours of
training at an orientation
didn't have the answers to basic
questions
what do you say to the on-call manager i
don't know i've never recorded one
honestly
conor holmes declined an interview but
said in a statement workers receive
regular training and the company strives
to exceed the legislated minimum
regulatory standards and yet former
workers say the kids who live there were
worse off when they left most are still
in trouble with the law or drugs they
just go down bad paths because nobody
cared about them so why should they care
about themselves carolyn jarvis global
news
and we continue our investigation into
connor homes tomorrow night with a deep
dive into the company's finances asking
are taxpayers dollars reaching kids in
need
hanging on to dear life next the
terrifying chaos for a construction
worker that's caught on camera
clearly something went terribly wrong a
construction worker found himself
dangling from a construction crane in
toronto high off the ground as mike
derle reports the whole ordeal was
captured on camera and before we show
you this video you should know the man
is okay
oh my god hang on
just let your heart out
it's unclear how high the man was up in
the air but if you look closely and
listen it takes three seconds for his
hard hat to hit the ground
the man was clearly terrified
yet as the video began circulating
online torontonians weren't exactly sure
how to react was it an accident a stunt
a scene from a movie
it sure seemed real
oh my god how the [ __ ] did this happen
but remember crane girl five years ago a
young woman climbed up on a crane to
snap some selfies before needing rescue
crews to help her get down
this it soon became apparent was not
that stop the construction company
reports the man got entangled with a
tagline after hooking a load and the
crane operator failed to notice
fortunately he was safely lowered to the
work surface and not seriously injured
the incident is under investigation the
company said in a statement
the ministry of labor said the worker
did suffer injuries reportedly a broken
wrist as he hung on for his life a few
minutes of abject terror confusion
and in the end relief
microlight global news toronto
holy smoke and that is global national
for this wednesday night i'm colleen
christie tonight's your canada is kenora
ontario we love to see your canada
please email your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you back
here tomorrow good night